So last Wednesday I asked to you to suspend disbelief and bear with me as we
worked our way through the parade oh system as a way of backing into the
political theory of John Stuart Mill,
which is going to be our subject today.
Um,
and I also promised you that as side benefit of,
of Wednesday's lecture,
which you would get to learn everything you ever needed to know about
neoclassical economics.
That in fact is true.
Um,
everything you ever do in economics is basically derived from our belt from
those simple ideas that Paredo and Edgeworth put together.
So,
um,
it is indeed I think a side benefit of working through it.
But now I'm,
what I want to do today is integrate what we saw in the parade oh system and the
remarks I made about Stevenson's emotive ism and philosophy and come,
uh,
into the central arguments in political theory that are informed by these mature
enlightenment ideas.
And you're going to see why I talk about the mature enlightenment with respect
to male further on in today's lecture.
Um,
as you can see here,
I talk about male as attempting to synthesize rights and utility and you might
think,
well,
okay,
how's he going to do that?
Some of you who know a little bit more about mill may also think it's,
it's odd that I've chosen his little essay called on liberty for you to read,
uh,
in,
in explaining his utilitarianism when in fact mail wrote an essay on
Utilitarianism,
which I'm not having you read,
although I'm certainly,
uh,
I'm,
I'm not prohibiting you from reading it,
but I think that um,
once you can see is that the synthesis of rights and utility can be approached
from either end.
And,
um,
I'm going to MPR approach it from the rights end,
uh,
at least initially and then we'll worry about the utilitarian end of things
later.
Um,
but I think males,
basic view is where they use start to develop a fully satisfying conception of
individual rights or whether you start to develop a fully sa satisfying
conception of utilitarianism,
you're going to end up incorporating the other one and those two into your
account.
Let me tell you a little bit about how John Stuart Mill was.
Um,
he was the son of James Male,
who had been a contemporary of Jeremy Bentham's.
Indeed not only a contemporary,
but actually a disciple of Bentham's and a true believer in Bentham's
utilitarianism,
including in the matter of the education of his son.
Um,
he was very,
uh,
concerned to give his son the most efficient possible education in order to get
them to achieve at the highest level.
And so he was what we would today call homeschooled.
I'm there.
We'll governesses and school teachers brought to his home.
He never went to school.
And in the aid,
he turned out to be an a brilliant child.
Uh,
he was doing it,
um,
a differential calculus at a very young age.
He was speaking Latin and Greek in his teens.
Uh,
he was just as an astonishingly smart child.
And so they,
um,
ramped up his education at an incredible clip with the result that by the age of
21,
he actually had a nervous breakdown.
He had no friends.
He had no life.
It was a measurable,
brilliant nerd.
And he never entirely recovered from that experience.
And nor did he ever quite absolve Bentham.
And his father's a single mindedness,
um,
from responsibility for doing that to him.
Uh,
and he was a somewhat pained and tortured person in late,
later in life.
I think he never quite shed the scars,
but his,
uh,
his wife Harriet,
who was a very interesting intellectual in her own right,
uh,
and wrote much of mill's famous essay that appeared over his name,
on the subjugation of women.
And indeed some mill scholars think that Harriet also had a big role in the
writing of,
on liberty,
but that's more a speculative.
Um,
so he never quite got over that early,
uh,
shotgun oil utilitarian education.
Um,
but he also never entirely shed the commitment to the idea that utilitarianism
is the best system for thinking about politics.
Uh,
at one point he says,
I do endorse utilitarianism,
but only in the largest sense of man as a progressive being.
And we'll come back to what that might mean,
uh,
as we proceed.
So mail does have one,
um,
useful characteristic in,
in common with Bentham.
I think it's the only one,
as I said that Ben Thumb was one of these monomaniacal people.
Um,
and what makes him a useful to us as he takes an idea and runs with it to the
absolute extreme.
And that's useful because you can see,
uh,
it's assumptions in a,
in a very sharp and stark light mill is somebody who's aware of the infinitely
complex nature of human existence and is not as a Johnny one note in the sense
that,
uh,
Bentham was,
and you'll see this very quickly as we get into his argument.
Nonetheless,
he shares in common with Bentham.
Um,
the feature that he reduces his doctrine to a single paragraph just as Bentham
data was the opening paragraph of his introduction to the principles of morals.
And I just lation with mill,
it comes about 12 pages in on the,
on the hack in addition that you're reading,
he says categorically,
the object of this essay is to serve a cert one very simple,
simple principle as entitled to govern absolutely sounds quite unequivocal.
The dealings of society with the Individual in the way of compulsion and
control,
whether the means be used be the physical force in the form of legal penalties
or the moral coercion of public opinion.
That principle is that these soul and for which band kind of warranted
individually or collectively in interfering with the liberty of action of any of
that number is self protection.
That the only purpose for which power can rightfully be exercised over any
member of a civilized community against his well is to prevent harm to others.
His own God,
either physical or moral is not a sufficient warrant.
He cannot rightfully be compelled to do or to forebear because it will be better
for him because it will make him happier because in the opinions of others to do
so would be wise or even right.
These are good reasons for Ramond straighting with a more reasoning with him or
persuading him [inaudible] treating him,
but not for compelling him or visiting him with any evil in Casey do otherwise
to justify that did that is to justify compelling him to conduct from which it's
desired to deter him.
Must be calculated to produce evil
must be calculated to produce evil to someone else.
The only part of the conduct of anyone for which he is amenable to society is
that which concerns others in the part which merely concerns himself.
These independence is a bright absolute over himself,
over his own body and mind.
The individual is sovereign.
Anyone think they have any doubt about what he's saying?
I mean,
setting aside whether you agree with it seems,
Hey,
one thing you feel pretty clear about what he's saying is put up there about
what he is saying.
Never mind whether we agree with that.
Understood.
Okay.
Well,
only one person feels clear,
I hope.
Feels unclear.
Bodies what he's saying.
So we have one person is clear.
Nobody who signed for a year and 136 undecided.
Wow.
I mean,
hey,
isn't it,
isn't it clear?
He's,
as I said,
I'm not asking you whether you agree,
it's just saying,
unless you harm somebody else,
you've got to be left alone
and the state must a leave you alone and be stop.
Anyone else who wants to interfere with you,
hearkening back to Bentham's point that uh,
the Lord should stay the hand of a third party,
right?
That's what he's saying here.
Yeah.
It's not rocket science.
Okay.
It'd be,
it's very direct.
Okay.
So that's what he's saying.
You might say.
Well,
okay.
Okay.
I mean it,
just to give you an example,
he's saying,
you know,
um,
if one of you comes to me at the end of this course and says,
I w professorship here,
or what do you write me a letter because I want to go to law school.
And I say,
well,
you know,
I've come,
come to know you and,
uh,
you've got a lot of good qualities and skills,
but you're just not,
you're not a lawyer.
Trust me,
I've been around a long time.
You should not go to law school.
The appropriate answer mail would say,
yes.
Well thank you for your opinion.
I'm not asking you to tell me what to do.
I,
you know,
I can play it with you.
I can remind straight with you,
I can try and persuade you.
But at the end of the day,
if you,
if you say,
well thank you very much,
but I,
I'm going to law school,
uh,
I run up at the end of I shouldn't try to coerce you.
And not only that,
I,
I shouldn't try and get others to put pressure on you.
Right?
It's not,
not only should you not be compelled,
but we shouldn't try and coerce shoe with the,
you know,
the moral force of public opinion.
We shouldn't start telling lawyer jokes,
uh,
to make you feel bad.
Right?
Yeah.
So we have to respect the autonomy of the individual complete opposite,
at least going in from where Bantham starch.
Right?
And one of the things you should see from this and you should,
should be starting to go through your mind,
um,
is that there is a deep structural identity between males harm principle and the
parade oh principle that we discussed last time.
I'll come back to that later.
But there's a basic structural identity between those two things.
Now you could say,
okay,
so male is saying,
yeah,
respect everybody's rights.
This is a strong theory of individual rights.
Unless somebody is harming somebody else,
they have to be left alone and the state has to make sure that they're going to
be left alone.
Fine.
That's just they,
we have rights.
But what does this have to do with utilitarianism?
Right?
How does mail get from protecting freedom of the individual,
this robust doctrine of individual rights to the notion that we're going to
maximize the utility in society.
Okay.
Anyone have any idea?
Anyone?
Yeah.
Yes sir.
Wait for the microphone.
Does he argue that freedom leads to the highest level of pleasure that,
uh,
an individual pursuing?
I guess given that type of freedom would gain utility from that and thus
maximizing that type of freedom to level.
Why do we gain utility come freedom.
Yeah.
Why?
Why,
why does,
in males mind,
why does maximizing freedom also maximize utility?
I mean,
you're right,
you're dead right?
But this,
there's an intermediate step.
What's the,
yeah.
Okay.
Over here,
according to mill,
only individual people can decide for themselves what makes them happy
according to Male.
Only individuals can decide for themselves what makes them happy.
That is also correct.
Um,
but there's still another step in this that I want us to focus on that neither
of you has mentioned yet.
Yeah.
Is that individuals knowing their own desires will bargain with one another.
Um,
using their freedom to,
to gain the mutual maximum youtube.
Very
good point.
And that that is where the identity with the predo principal comes in.
If you leave people alone,
right,
they will do what they want with themselves or not.
We'll all with others.
And so what males harm principle allows in politics is the sort of analog of
what the Predo Prince,
what's we were calling Paredo superior in economics.
That's also true,
but it's not what I was looking for a right now though,
there's no reason you should know that because you can't read my mind.
But this another step.
Thank thank back to the big picture.
The big picture is all these enlightenment theories are committed both to the
freedom of individual and to scientific truth.
Right?
Male is an enlightenment thinker of the first order.
If you flip,
throw your whole copy of on liberty,
you will see what is the longest chapter about?
What is the longest chapter about?
It's probably half of the book.
Freedom of thought and discussion,
right?
Freedom of speech.
So why is freedom of speech so important?
Because mail thanks.
That is the path to the truth.
Freedom of speech is the path to the truth.
Now,
I want to spend a little bit of time on this because it's really important.
It's really important
for two reasons.
The first is you're going to see a very different conception of science
informing mills work.
Remember back to our discussion of the early enlightenment of Hobbes and Locke
of Ben Bentham.
That truth was equated with certainty.
Remember,
they got the,
Oh,
the 17th century people had this weird route to this because it wasn't what we
think of as a priority truths,
but things that were a product of wells and all that,
right?
But,
Oh,
you enlightenment.
Idea of science is to find certainty,
right?
Cart DAZN doubt.
Remember,
he's looking for propositions that cannot be doubted.
Things that can be known with certainty.
Male is a fallible last male,
has a much more modern conception of science.
The one that you intuitively have,
which says first of all that um,
all knowledge is cartridge,
a ball,
all propositions,
uh,
have to be evaluated by reference to evidence and the scientific method.
And we could always be wrong in doing that,
uh,
in our attempts to do that.
So a very important move in the history of the philosophy of science in this
regard was to move away from talking about what philosophers used to use the
word verification ism,
proving that a scientific theory is correct and instead starting to talk about
falsification,
ism proving that it hasn't yet been falsified.
And so any of you who takes a statistic scores,
uh,
in,
in the social sciences will know what you have is a hypothesis and empirical
hypothesis saying,
you know,
a
high tax rates,
cores,
um,
hike tracks,
rights lead to,
to inflation and you go and you will,
you'll test it against the evidence and it,
you'll have some other hypothesis that that will be called the competing
hypothesis.
So the now hypothesis and all you'll ever be able to say is that your,
your hypothesis hasn't been shown to be false.
You don't never know you,
you'll never know for certain that some other hypothesis couldn't do better.
Okay,
so false.
This is falsification.
Sm is the idea that would eventually become,
uh,
associated with the f the philosopher called popper,
who we don't read in this course,
but it's this idea that um,
knowledge claims are carriage,
all our knowledge claims might be wrong,
and the scientific attitude involves recognizing that and acting accordingly.
So it's the mature enlightenment.
Conception of science means you have to be committed to an s finding the truth
as an ongoing quest.
And this is really important for male,
okay?
So freedom of speech is really important for male as a path to the truth,
as the path to the truth,
okay?
Now that's one reason it's important.
The second is that male injects into
a desirable political system.
The importance of argument arguing,
okay,
this is going to come up again and again in the course,
particularly in the last section when we get to democratic theory,
when I say mill talks about the importance of argument,
this is very different from deliberation.
It's not the idea that we should all get together and hold hands and sing
Kumbaya and see what we can agree about.
That's the sort of deliberative ideal,
right?
The liberation arguing my days.
How many here have seen prime minister's questions on TV?
Right?
That's argument.
Okay,
well cross fire,
uh,
the TV program,
that's argument where people whole the best criticisms they can come up with
against the other side.
It's,
it's not surprising they were male is often how to be responsible for the
metaphor of the competition of ideas.
These are two very different models of the role of speech in politics.
Just to give you an example of what's at stake here,
there's a lot of experimental work that's been done on it by social
psychologists.
Um,
okay.
On this question.
So suppose,
suppose as a field and in the middle of the field there is a cow.
Okay.
And we're all standing around the field.
Looking at the cow and the question is what does the cow way,
I'm think about two ways of tackling this question.
One would be that we all discuss what,
what do you think the cow ways,
what do you think of ways and we eventually reached some agreement upon what we
think the cow ways and we go with that number.
Okay.
The second approach would be to say we don't talk to each other at all.
Each of us looks at the cow and makes our own best judgment about what the cow
ways we add them all up and divide it by the number of people.
Which which method you think is more likely to get the white of the cow
accurate?
How many people think the deliberative method hands up for the liberal of the
method?
Yeah.
Okay.
It looks like about a third of you.
How many for the,
the non deliberative additive method.
Okay,
so you went to to one.
Well it turns out you're right,
it turns out,
um,
okay.
That the,
the non deliberative additive method is raw,
gets to the,
gets the answer right?
Almost.
Exactly.
Whereas the deliberative method goes all over the place.
Now there's lots of speculation about why
now,
why one,
one reason could be,
while the trouble with the deliberative method he has,
you know,
it,
it's going to lead people to listen to strong personalities or people who think
they know more than they do.
You know,
lay on need.
They're over there.
Says,
look,
you know,
I grew up on a farm.
I don't tell me about cows.
I know everything there is to know God cows.
Why don't you people know?
And I say that a cow is where it weighs 1500 pounds,
you know,
and then a lot of other people say,
well,
he did,
he grew up on a farm.
Where do I know?
And so maybe opinion gets swayed in that way.
That's that.
That's one possible reason.
Um,
people make copy what other people say just because they,
they,
they don't know it Cetera.
But for whatever reason,
and we could speculate and when we come to talk about deliberative democracy
later,
we'll go into it more.
Um,
I just wanted to flag this distinction.
That argument is not deliberation.
Okay?
And so,
um,
when Michelle talks about argument,
it's,
it's rare that this idea that um,
everybody makes their own independent judgment.
Uh,
he wants our,
our capacity to make that judgment to be strengthened,
but that's not the same thing as deliberation.
He wants us to have our own individual robust judgments and trust them.
Okay?
That is,
that is his ideal
and we should never ever kowtow to the opinions of others.
This is not a deliberative model.
And indeed male gives us four reasons for thinking that freedom of speech is
important.
For one thing,
he says,
yeah,
this,
this is the
point about Falabella awesome.
He says,
if any opinion is compelled to silence that opinion for all we might know might
be true,
to deny that is to assume our infallibility.
So science is not about certainty.
It's not about faith,
right?
It's recognizing that whatever we say might be wrong.
Secondly though is silenced opinion be in error.
It may and very commonly does contain a portion of the truth and since the
general prevailing opinion on any subject is rarely or never the whole truth,
it is only by the collision of adverse opinions.
That's prime minister's questions.
That is crossfire,
the collision of adverse opinions
that the remainder of the truth has any chance of being supplied.
Third,
even if the received opinion be not only true,
but the whole truth,
unless it has suffered to be an actually is vigorously and turn and earnestly
contested it well by most of those who receive it be held in the manner of a
prejudice with little comprehension or feeling of it's rational grounds.
That is you don't want to only get the right answer,
you want to get the right answer for the right reason.
If you copy somebody math assignment when you can't do the problem,
you have the right answer,
but you haven't got the right answer for the right reason.
And not only this,
but fourthly,
the meaning of the doctrine itself will be in danger of being lost or in feeble
and deprived of its vital effect on the character and conduct the dogma of
becoming a mere formal profession in effect,
Keisha's for good,
but cumbering the ground and preventing the growth of any real and heartfelt
conviction from reason or personal experience.
So you can say that male is in some ways what we would think of today as a
libertarian.
He's got this idea of freedom of speech.
We should all be left alone to do is we like without interference from the
state,
except when the state stops others from interfering with us,
right?
What Nozick will later call the night watchman,
state of liberal theory,
this negative freedom standard libertarian view.
On the other hand,
he's also a kind of romantic individualist,
right?
He sees individual human flourishing.
Somebody said he had the path,
the path to happiness.
Everybody knows they're the in our own sources of utility.
Nobody can tell you what makes you happy.
This is the link just Stevenson we were talking about last time.
I can't tell you what should be in your utility function.
I don't know.
No interpersonal comparisons of utility.
That's the link to parade [inaudible] so you can see in all of these fields this
move to,
it's not miss objectivism,
it's the romantic celebration of subjectivism,
right?
The,
the full flourishing of your potential can only happen if you
are allowed
total freedom of speech,
of,
of anything you want to do.
Yeah.
So long as you don't harm others.
And this is important not just for your own individual utility function,
but also because that's how society learns the Truth and truth is going to be
important for the pursuit of utility.
You need these tough minded credit.
We should all be in,
you know.
Whereas for Locke,
we were all miniature gods who have maker's knowledge of our creation for Loc
were all minute four,
four mil.
We're all managers,
scientists.
We should,
we've got to have the critical attitude and we,
you can't learn,
get a critical attitude if you're,
if you're copying other people's math,
you have to be able to defend your reasoning to all commas.
You have to stand there.
Like Gordon Brown at Question Time and have people hurl counter examples at you,
not people who are trying to get your agreement.
Okay.
It's the combat of ideas that the clash of ideas,
that's the truth comes out as a byproduct of that.
Just as in the invisible hand theory of markets,
that truth is a byproduct.
It efficiency is a byproduct of lots of individual transactions.
Right?
Yeah.
So that,
that is uh,
that is the,
the connection if you like,
between males idea of the importance of each individual getting the truth for
themselves and the parade.
Oh,
principle.
In both cases it's an invisible hand explanation,
which says as a byproduct of this utilitarian efficiency is maximized.
Yeah.
That's why the chapter on freedom of speech is central to this doctrine.
Okay.
So all well and good you might say,
but
how many read the,
to the end,
the chapter on applications
all starts to unravel,
it seems once we get to the chapter on applications.
Yeah.
Mel says in many cases an individual but suing a little legitimate object
necessarily and therefore legitimate causes pain or loss to others.
Oh,
NSF.
A good which they had a reasonable hope of attaining such opposition of interest
between individuals often arise from bad social institutions,
but a unavoidable while those institutions last and some would be unavoidable
under any institutions.
Whoever succeeds in an overcrowded profession
or in a competitive examination,
whoever is preferred to a Nada in any contest for an object which both isyeah
rapes benefit from the loss of others from their wasted exertion and
disappointment,
but it is by common admission better for the general interest of mankind.
That person should pursue their objects undeterred by this sort of consequences.
In other words,
society admits no right either legal or moral in the disappointed competitors to
impunity from this kind of suffering and feels called on to interfere only when
means of success of employed being employed,
which is contrary to the general interest to permit namely fraud or treachery
and force.
What's the problem with all of that?
It's not exactly eloquent,
but what?
What?
What is the,
what's the problem?
There is an isn't their problem?
Maybe there's no problem.
That's called a clue.
What's the problem?
Yeah.
According to this,
couldn't you reason that something like the Holocaust was okay if it's in the
general interest of mankind or any kind of
yeah,
Mitch is a big problem,
right?
I mean,
did he say earlier Ron,
that um,
people can't be coerced into accepting results just because the majority
believes that under any wind out of his way,
he went out of his way to say,
yeah.
Whether it's the actions of the majority or the moral coercion of public
opinion,
but he's saying,
but it is by common admission better that we have competitive exams.
Of course the people who don't get the job or harmed but still bad.
Seems like a contradiction.
No.
Yeah.
Give another example again,
trade as a social act whereby undertake stock to sell any description of goods
to the public does what affects the interest of other persons and society in
general.
And that's his conduct in principle comes within the jurisdiction of society.
Accordingly,
it was once Hal to be the duty of governments in all cases,
which were considered of importance to fix prices and regulate the process of
manufacturer.
But it is now recognized now,
not this love,
this passive voice.
It is now recognized though,
not til after a long struggle,
that both the cheapness and the quality of commodities are more effectively
provided for by leaving the producers and sellers perfectly free under the sole
check of equal freedom to the bias of supplanting themselves elsewhere.
This is so called doctrine of free trade.
Would dress on grounds different from though equally solid with the principle of
liberty asserted in this essay?
Yeah,
same problem,
right?
It is not recognized by home.
Why should we believe that?
And more importantly,
aren't we supposed to be protected from the dominant view?
Right?
So free trade,
we,
you know,
we think about the arguments we have today.
This is a century later with the arguments we have about outsourcing.
Yes.
Uh,
they harm the interest of American workers when they move factories to Mexico.
But males saying,
yeah,
it's true,
but you know,
free trades better.
It's better from the standpoint of utilitarianism.
Big a problem.
It seems.
You think Mel was just actually not that smart.
He didn't see this huge contradiction sort of.
Right.
Okay.
The minute you start to apply this doctrine,
it all just
turns to sand.
Anyone think there's a way out of this from male?
Yeah.
Well people have been struggling with us ever since he wrote it
because it does seem to be a big problem.
But on the other hand,
the Alere of this rights utility synthesis is so great that people want to find
a white to solve it.
And I think this is how Mel thought about this.
There's no contradiction at all.
I think that male thanks in terms of a two step test,
step one is you say
of any proposed action,
is there going to be harm to somebody else?
So,
uh,
smoking marijuana
or in more,
I guess contextually appropriate at the time prohibition.
This is a case that Mel considered,
uh,
in,
in what you read.
If you go,
if you go to your room and you get paralytic drunk or you get stoned and you
sleep it off,
you're not harming anybody.
Okay.
So it's protected.
Oh,
Mel was a libertarian in that sense.
And you post prohibition,
which was a very live issue,
uh,
when he was writing.
Okay.
But there are a lot of activities where it's inevitable that there's going to be
hard.
You know?
Yes,
it's true that protectionism harm some people,
but any trade regimes going to harm some people,
right?
So,
uh,
I'm sorry,
free trade arms,
American workers,
but protectionism harms African workers or Indonesian workers,
right?
Whatever you do for a trade policy,
they're going to,
there's going to be somebody who's going to be harmed or whatever system you
have for giving away jobs in the civil service.
Whoever doesn't get the job's going to be harmed.
If you have pure competition,
uh,
the people who don't get the highest scores are going to be harmed.
Uh,
if you,
if you have,
you know,
a job reservation for whites as they had in South Africa,
then,
um,
blacks are not going to get the jobs.
If you have affirmative action to remedy past injustices,
um,
in the Connecticut Fire Department,
then,
um,
the paper who would otherwise have have gotten the jobs are going to be harmed
as the court supreme court said.
And,
and,
uh,
last year.
So males point is you first make an inquiry.
Is there a harm?
If the answer's no,
the action south regarding,
again,
it's protected.
Free speech doesn't hurt anybody.
Okay?
That's why it's so important to protect it.
Indeed,
he wants to say the externalities of free speech,
a positive we speech doesn't hurt anybody.
Drinking doesn't hurt anybody.
Now somebody,
some of you might question that.
You might say,
well
if you,
okay,
you go to a bar and you get paralytic drunk and you are,
and you then get behind the wheel of a car and you go home and you kill
somebody,
drinking dies harm.
Why do you think mail would say to that?
I think Mel would say,
well,
that's a reason to,
to penalize drunk driving but not drinking.
Right?
So I think,
I think that's what he'd say to that.
But so the first step is you,
you ask,
is there a harm to others?
If the answer's no,
it's protected by the harm principle.
If the answer is yes,
there's a harm to others,
then you make a utilitarian calculation as to what's best for society.
So if there's a harm to others,
then you make the utilitarian calculation.
And that's why it's important to have good science.
Because when you make the utilitarian calculation,
you want to bring the best scientific knowledge to bear on making that
calculation.
He doesn't trust majority opinion,
right?
He wants to say free trade is better than protectionism.
We now know that as a matter of economic science,
when he was riding,
if somebody could come along and show that there's something other than free
trade,
that would be even better,
then we would pick that.
Okay.
So,
um,
it's not the case that he wants to say this is,
you know,
infallible knowledge are known for all time.
But for the moment,
the best scientific judgment when I'm writing this book on Liberty Male says,
is that free tried,
maximizes utility.
So step one,
is there a harm?
If no,
it's protected.
If yes,
then you make the utilitarian calculation and then it's important to have good
science behind you,
not majority opinion.
Right?
And that's freedom of speech is the pathway
from liberty too.
Utilitarian efficiency.
And that's why all good things go together in Mel's account.
And we can have this hunky dory synthesis of rights and utility.
Yeah.
Right.
Now we're going to go more deeply into
this question
on Wednesday,
whether it is all Hunky Dory.
Um,
because you know,
I've said now,
well,
there's a two step test for determining harm and that makes sense and it makes
the apparent contradiction go away.
And I think it is the best reconstruction of what mill wanted to say,
even though he could have said it more clearly if he had come out and done that.
Um,
nonetheless,
there's still the question of who gets to decide what counts as a relevant harm.
I said,
you do the first,
the first stage is there harm,
but just from the little example I gave of drunk and driving and drinking,
you can see that this might be problematic.
One of the things I want to thank you to think about between non Wednesdays,
some other examples such as prostitution.
MMM.
Does that involve harm to others or not?
Okay.
I don't want to answer that now.
Just think about it.
I want to ask you that on Wednesday.